>>presenter: Lester Wunderman is a true living
legend of the advertising world.
The founder of Wunderman and widely credited
as the father of modern day direct marketing.
Mr. Wunderman's career began before World
War II and continues to this day.
At 92 years old he still comes to the office
every day.
Mr. Wunderman is the originator of the first
customer rewards card, the first toll free
800 number, amongst other innovations.
The life and career of Wunderman's Chairman
Emeritus spans the most formative years of
advertising, but also bridges to this modern
era of customer engagement in a way that is
impossible to ignore.
Lester was elected to the Direct Marketing
Hall of Fame in 1983.
The Advertising Hall of Fame in 1998, and
was named on the twenty Advertising Legends
and Leaders by AdWeek in 1998.
In addition to his many achievements in the
advertising industry, Mr. Wunderman is also
a consultant, professor, author, and accomplished
photographer.
Pieces of Lester's collection can be found
in the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
So please join me in welcoming Lester Wunderman.
[Applause]
>>presenter: So Lester, we are in the year
2012, obviously, but take us back to early
1950's, the world that you saw at that point,
and the opportunity that you uncovered around
this notion of direct marketing.
What was going on that gave you the idea that
there was this market need that you could
fulfill?
>>Lester Wunderman: Well, I think the first
thing I noticed as we begin to get into advertising
was that it was all about the product and
it had nothing to do with the consumer.
There was little research, but consumers and
everything, all the media whether it be print
or radio or television there were jingles
about products and they might have been silly
little jingles, but they wanted you to remember
the name of the product.
They were not trying to fit into your life;
they were trying to fit it into your memory.
So I thought it was kind of a shallow practice.
We didn't have it that easy, my brother and
I. I had a brother who is three years older;
what happened was my mother who had been widowed
for quite a long time; my father died, I told
you when I was nine and she was widowed and
he had left her; he had run a successful business
so she was left with some assets and among
them was the jewelry that he had bought her
during their romantic years and she says to
my brother I had a lousy job I was making
ten dollars I got raised I think ten dollars
a week as an office boy in a collection agency
and the boss called me in and said I want
to give you a raise of twenty percent, I would
make twelve dollars a week.
I said to him, “Sir I understand that the
President passed that law of Minimum Wage
Act last week, but I thank you very much.”
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: It was no great benefit.
In any event, world the was under the influence
of certain radio stars people like you may
or may not heard of, people like Eddie Cantor
and others who were comedians of those days.
There was a newsman by the name of [inaudible]
who started his program with “Uh-huh, there's
good news tonight”, whether there was or
not.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: I remember he invited
down to his house in Florida to show me how
he prepared his broadcast.
It was one of the more embarrassing periods
of my life because I had clients listening
in and I had been at the poolside before this
interview.
At the poolside was this gorgeous blonde who
was drinking martinis
>>presenter: Uh oh.
>>Lester Wunderman: As nothing would have
it but then I would drink martinis with her.
By the time I got to the radio station and
began to broadcast, I dropped the script.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: And they could here, I
mean transmitted with the sound of this script;
this paper dropping, and my scrambling to
get back up.
[laughing] You know, we someone got through
that.
I called the client and said how'd you like
to broadcast?
He says fine, but what was all that noise?
I said I don't know, must have been your set.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: So in any event, life
back in those days was if you read the book
The Hucksters, which came out many years ago
it was a different world we were not organized
as we are now into advertising agencies now
is serious businesses and to the best of my
knowledge, I don't know anybody in our company
who drinks martinis at lunch or would or any
of our clients that would suggest it.
I mean we're serious people going about doing
serious work and you know those days the wildness
of those days.
I'll tell you a story, school I just won't
mention names, but I had a client in the entertainment
business and their stores their people kept
going out to California and registering in
a boarding house that turned out to be a brothel.
[audience laughing] So when I went out there
we had in those days we used to have planning
sessions in exotic places so we had a planning
session in Palm Springs.
And I'm sitting there with our clients in
Palm Springs and a car drives up and this
kind of burly looking woman gets out and she
says I want my money and I'll give you the
book.
So, they got terrified and they asked me would
you negotiate with this woman please.
So it turned out she had the registration
book since she passed herself off as a rooming
house people have to register as if they were
having rooms.
They were having women, but seems as if they
were having rooms.
So she said for a hundred thousand dollars,
I will sell you this book.
That stunned me.
And at that time our treasurer was our art
director.
[laughing] Don't ask me why it went together,
but it did and I called him on the phone and
I said is there any way you can scrabble up
a hundred thousand dollars [audience laughing]
in cash and fly out here to California and
give me the cash and go home and don't ask
me any questions?
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: So that's what happened.
He came out, gave me a hundred thousand dollars
and flew back.
And then I was to negotiate with this woman.
So I paid her the hundred thousand dollars
and suddenly I had the book.
I was determined not to look in that book
because I didn't want to have any information
that would prejudice my relationships with
my clients.
So I put the book in a bank vault and I told
them that this book was in a bank vault and
nobody was going to see it and I had not looked
at it.
About three years later they called me and
said let's have a book burning.
We have a celebration.
We had a party they burned the book.
I never saw it.
[laughing] All I saw was the binding, but
in advertising that wouldn't happen today
I mean it's just not
[Laughter]
>>presenter: So how did you introduce the
kind of discipline this whole notion of accountability
return on investment I mean these were all
very, very new concepts at the time.
How did you wrangle that?
>>Lester Wunderman: Because we were not part
of the world of advertising.
I mean we didn't engage in the activities
that the agency world was kind of famous for
in those days and written about in this book
The Hucksters, which was written back then.
So we were serious men trying to make a living
and we had a little office down in Union Square
and we did everything.
I would go to the roof of a building and walk
down and stop at every office and try to sell
them whatever I could, printing, writing,
advertising, and whatever.
And one day I got down to the eighth floor
of a building and there was a man hanging
out the window trying to kill himself so I
ran over grabbed him and pulled him out of
the window and sat on him on the floor.
He was kicking and screaming and yelling in
a foreign language and I didn't know what
the foreign language was.
Finally, he calmed down and he took me into
his office and offered me a drink.
It turned out that he was a Russian who had
been in the Czar's court quite famously.
One of the women of the court-- the nature
of the Russian Court, was that women gave
men presents of unique items--and somebody
had given him, a woman had given him a bottle
of a skin lotion that had never been on the
market; she invented it, and she gave him
the formula for it.
When the revolution came in Russia, he moved
to Paris and began making this stuff, which
was quite popular.
He came to New York and he couldn't sell it.
He had this psoriasis situation where at the
time was incurable and just itched the scratch.
So between the fact that he couldn't sell
his skin lotion and it didn't work on him,
he was going to kill himself.
So when I save him he said: “What can I
do for you?
What can I do, you saved my life?”
I said to him “Give me your advertising
account.”
[Audience laughing]
>>presenter: True entrepreneur.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: But the world you know
getting clients we got; we got another client
who is a woman from the old west and she had
gone to France and married a French Nobleman,
a Count.
This was during World War II so the Count
was busy fighting and she came back to New
York and decided to start a business and she
had a patent on a turntable that was put in
store windows with props on top and the store
demonstrator.
So she had an extraordinary advertising budget
to sell these things and of course when it
came time to pay her bill there was no payment.
After two months of that [inaudible] we owed
media as much capital as we had.
So I went to her apartment—she lived in
the East sixties--and I begged her I said
“You know we're not talking business we're
talking about food for family.
We're going to starve if you don't pay this
bill.”
I really turned it on as hard as I could so
she gave me a check.
Delighted.
I mean I was skipping like Charlie Chaplin.
The next day I went to the bank the teller
looked at me and says “You have another
one.”
I said “Another one of what?”
“Bad check.”
says she.
That was the end of that.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: From there we decided
that we'd better find employment-- that our
business ability-- business executive acumen
was not ready.
So we went to work for another advertising
agency and from there on I pogoed from one
agency to another until we finally started
our own which was quite successful and then
merged it with Young & Rubicam.
Everybody wanted it.
What happened is the four A's which was American
Association of Advertising Agencies rates
agencies by their profitability.
They sent a special inspection team over to
our office and said we don't believe that
can make the kind of profit you make and provide
service as well.
So I said “Fine here's the list of our clients
go talk to them see if they get any service.”
Well after about two weeks he came back and
he said “I want to make a special case.
At the next Advertising Agency Convention
down at the Greenbrier I want to introduce
you as somebody who knows more about making
a profit than anybody I have yet met.”
So what happens up on the stage for a couple
of kids it was
>>presenter: So you manage to go from the
Russian immigrant with the skin lotion [uh
huh] to one of the most profitable agencies
at the time and one of your big clients was
American Express [yeah] and we actually got
a copy of the original business plan that
Lester wrote actually launching the American
Express Card.
It's about fifty pages.
It is the type of work that would probably
be done by Bain or McKinsey today in terms
of the level of analysis the case that was
built for introducing this card.
Give us the back story there.
How did that all happen?
>>Lester Wunderman: Well the back story was
that they really didn't know what they wanted.
They had a very strange Chief Executive Officer.
He was not quite as sharp as the people--
there are wonderful executives under him but
he himself
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: Yeah he was the founder.
So he came to us and he said I'll give you
five thousand dollars for an idea.
I said what idea?
He said the one you'll think of.
[Audience laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: So he gave us five thousand
dollars and for that I made that report as
to how and why they should have a credit card
and what it should offer how they should go
about it how we would market it.
The whole report as you saw and that was the
five thousand dollars.
In addition they were—Ogilvy and Mather
was their agency and still is.
With very close ties in there and no other
agency could get in.
But finally as a result of what we had done
they made us their second agency and we began
to get to share with Ogilvy and Mather projects.
As a result I got to know David pretty well
because David took care of American Express
himself.
By and large he had a woman named Shelly Lazarus
who worked under him, but he was really in
charge of that account.
He was a charmer, he really was.
>>presenter: So the charge card for American
Express and then there was another invention
of yours which is the 800 number.
>>Lester Wunderman: Well we wanted what happened
was we were missing—The most lively media
of that period was radio and television.
And the greater audiences that had supported
the magazines such as The Saturday Evening
Post or [inaudible] or Life Magazine which
had seven million circulation were being distressed
by the fact that radio and television were
becoming so important to the American family
and to the American advertiser.
So we began to look into how we could get
clients who would use that media and those
media and clients never been-- I mean all
the clients we had suddenly ended up I invented
something that became classic.
The 800 number was a way of responding to
an advertisement at the cost to the advertiser.
So that if they asked you on the commercial
to buy the product or to get some information
the charge was made against the advertisers
cost, not the consumer's cost.
So from that-- but there was no telephone
access.
What happened you know radio commercial and
television were just so snappy so fast thirty
seconds some of them even twenty or ten seconds.
It was over in a minute and you want to answer
it because that's offered you something that
you'd like to have.
Well, to drag out a piece of paper or envelope
and see if you have a postage stamp as do--
most people got lost in that process.
So we thought why not you have a form of mail
that would be charged to the average us and
so we developed what's called 800-number and
when people could freely call a telephone
representative or a company's telephone room
and charge what they want to get.
And the 800 number that became like free phone
what they called in Europe “free phone”
and we invented it and we used it and suddenly
budgets were do so much larger because we
could now use through the major media that
we couldn't use before.
So that was the 800 number.
Also we invented-- nobody had ever done this
we invented an operator who we put on television.
She came into the commercial when the urge
to call was made and she introduced herself
my name is Peggy [mumbling] whatever her name
was and I'm here and when you call this number
it’s likely I who will answer the phone
and I look forward to your call.
That had never happened before.
The 800 number kind of a mystery you know
didn't know who you were going to get.
Suddenly, this friendly young woman she wouldn't
do anything bad to me.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: Anyway, I want to talk
to her…Oh I know her name was Judy.
>>presenter: Judy, Peggy.
>>Lester Wunderman: It was Judy.
I mean we named her Judy.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: “Call Judy”.
And Judy was a Connecticut housewife who had
had some experience in broadcast and she became
famous because there she was at the end of
the commercials saying: “This is Judy and
here's my number and if you call me I'll make
sure that you get what you're ordering.”
That had never happened before there was never
a phone number that had a live person; it
was always just, 800-number.
>>presenter: Right.
>>Lester Wunderman: So that's changed things.
Very successful.
>>presenter: And even with just coming up
with that kind of innovation what was the
process internally?
Was it just troubleshooting, looking at things
that were working, weren't working, research?
How did you get to those?
>>Lester Wunderman: I studied and taught creative
thinking.
I studied at Columbia.
They had courses in creative thinking and
it was a new school they had a course in creative
thinking.
I also studied at NYU where they had courses
in marketing pretty good courses at the downtown
school, but I learned--oh and also I became
a member of the American Theater wing practicing
to be an actor, but what I learned American
Theatre wing was stage craft and how you get
an audience involved.
So I educated myself and you know I was a
kid born in the Bronx whose father died at
nine and I was a very bright student.
I was two years ahead of my age group.
>>presenter: Skipping.
>>Lester Wunderman: Skipping yeah.
So, so you know I always had I always realized
that imagination could solve problems that
the systemic ideas might not.
There were new ways and better ways to do
things.
And since I was not part of the establishment
in any way I had to find ways of doing things
that were better, more impressive.
So we can get clients because of the unique
ideas we had because we couldn't compete with
the big agencies.
>>presenter: Fantastic.
So in your talk at MIT you said advertising
must not only sell the consumer on the idea
of trying the product but it must cause him
to continue buying it as well.
So by this standard how would you rate today's
advertising?
What are people doing well?
What could they be doing better?
>>Lester Wunderman: Bad.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: There is no and this is
something I wish in my lifetime I could get
done.
Nobody thinks of lifetime values.
Nobody thinks that a customer has a lifetime
value and therefore you can invest against
that lifetime value not invest against or
bank that they’ll try your products.
So the budgets can be multiplied for that
purpose if you're good enough to get people
to try and continue to use your product.
Now, it’s a mess today.
The advertisers only want you to go to the
supermarket that they get instead of the competition.
They have-- I never heard anybody extending
forward the idea that this product and your
use of it would do some good.
For example your own business, Google, supposing
I have a wallet… and supposing they have
a wallet until retiring at the age of 65.
If they have spent a lot of money on their
wallets should they be rewarded when they
no longer have income?
Could you set aside a portion of their revenue
to do so.
I don’t know if it’s practical.
But that's the system of thinking that, that
if you want people to use your product continuously
you have to make investments and give advantages
for that happening.
And American marketers do not do any anything
of that kind.
Ford Motor Company, our client, for example,
doesn't incent you to buy five cars in your
lifetime or six and maybe they give you the
seventh one.
I mean there's just no conversation of that
kind and there ought to be.
And I think what ought to come next in advertising,
consumer benefit is that you have a period
in life which is gainful for your earning
and during that period you're as comfortable
as that earning makes you.
Then you come to a point where you get Social
Security which is far less than your wage
was.
You may have a pension which will be far less
than your wage was.
So your center of living dips.
Something has to be done to recognize the
fact that for thirty or forty or fifty years
I have contributed to this economy and the
companies, and if I was loyal to certain of
them and I made great profits for them, at
a point that I become needy, they should find
some way of repaying me with something.
And I think that's just a step that may happen
because loyalty, I mean repurchase is all
that makes a profit.
What makes a profit is if somebody buys a
brand and continues to buy it they're profitable.
I don't see money spent against loyalty and
there should be.
>>presenter: So staying on that theme of advertising
today and the problems that you've outlined
there've obviously been lots of innovations
still and we have Google and all of the innovation
that this organization has made in the advertising
and technology media world.
You have the Facebooks of the world, Twitter,
all of these new things.
Give us your take on how you see them impacting
marketing, advertising, consumer value, all
of the things you've just talked about.
>>Lester Wunderman: Well, in creating all
these companies you mentioned they're creating
groups.
It's kind of a loyalty program creating groups
that have in common the use of a product or
service and people like to know people who
do what they do.
And I think with media such as the internet
and what will happen beyond the currents state
of such a digital communication which things
will happen I mean, it’s not over, that
they would get into these companies will realize
that they are investing against a lifetime
value of the customer and not investing against
the trial sale.
And when that happens the budgets will increase,
the language will change, the offerings and
methods of sale change, and it's also true
of a retailer.
If a retailer signs up somebody who will continue
some product, the retailer should benefit.
In other words, you should have a subscription
idea that penetrates the whole distribution
marketplace and communications so that people
incented to stay with the brand, stay with
the product, and are advantaged by doing so.
It will happen.
I mean, I’m gonna try to make it happen.
[Laughter]
>>Lester Wunderman: You know, but Google I
think could also have a point in that kind
of a world.
I mean you know you're set up for it.
That's all.
[Laughter]
>>presenter: So I do want to open up the mics
and invite questions from the audience and
while you guys are getting your questions
in line just a bit of a shift in terms of
your other interests.
Because not only are you a pioneer in the
advertising space but you're also an accomplished
photographer, your work is shown in the Metropolitan
Museum of Art.
What holds the most important place in your
heart these days?
Do you focus on photography?
>>Lester Wunderman: I studied photography
at several institutions.
There was a thing known as the Photo League
in the old days we'd go study.
I studied at NYU, I studied at Columbia, and
then I studied with a couple of very important
photographers.
It's a serious aesthetic and I find it a very
satisfying activity not just what you take
but what you make of what you take is that
one image that you showed what you can do
today digitally that you can modify images
so that you are much like a Picasso.
Picasso has a model, uh, you don’t end up,
he doesn’t end up painting that model realistically
as the older more ancient painters did.
He's not trying to show that he can be photographic.
He's trying to show all the ins and outs of
that person's personality and features and
I think we're beginning to be able to do that
digitally with images.
So if you look, would look at my images you'll
see all the photographs that I've taken in
many parts of the world.
I traveled a lot because our company is so
widespread.
And I have them on my computer and there are
so many software systems now that you can
use either alone or in combination to make
a photo that is yours.
It's not the object you photographed it's
the object in your mind, which a lot of painters
do.
So that's what I'm doing.
The other think I'm doing is I'm writing two
books at the moment.
As you can imagine I'm always restless.
[Laughter]
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Lester Wunderman: Age so far…who was it?
Blake who wrote rage, rage, rage at the passing
of the sun?
But I don't rage, rage, rage.
I create, create, create.
I think one way to offset your physical decay
as you age is to have mental and imaginative
growth.
>>presenter: Yes.
>>Lester Wunderman: And I think this opportunity
should be opened up so all senior citizens
that they have something to say, they have
things they saw, they have things they know
and society is made up of a kind of folklore
created by the common action and do I'm doing
it myself and it's being distributed and I
have worked in thirteen museums.
You know, I've got one book published and
now I'm going to have two more.
So I like where I am.
>>presenter: That's obviously sage wisdom
and advice.
I think that another thing that the group
would probably be interested in hearing from
your around is we are challenged every day
by clients and agencies to help them reinvent
transform in the context of this new world.
They're looking to us for advice similar to
the advice that your clients have been soliciting
from you for some time.
What advice would you give us in terms of
being better partners, better thinkers, better
collaborators with our clients?
>>Lester Wunderman: Listen, you are amazing.
You're a relatively new company and you're
well known, well established I think considering
the period of time that you've been doing
this.
You've made great strides.
And ideas come from ideas.
I think you'll find within your organization
you don't even have to go outside that will
help in any way.
You can if you want, but I think within your
group there are probably enough imaginations
if they’re encouraged to be creative.
I used to run when brainstorming became the
word.
That's among the things I've learned-- went
to Columbia to learn--was brainstorming.
You take the thought and convert it into an
idea and then the group keeps marinating until
something shows up.
And you can do that with I did it our company
did it I had a round table and I won't do
it anymore because we have creative assets
and I'm not that's not my job anymore, but
I think that you can get a lot of excitement
and innovation out of your own people if you
listen to them.
Everybody has ideas and I think that that's
the thing that should be known.
It isn’t just people like myself who are
creative people.
Everybody is capable of having an idea.
We tested it.
We used to do brainstorming, for example one
of things at Columbia they had us do.
They'd say how many uses could you find for
a brick?
Suddenly, the class would get involved, maybe
with a hundred uses for a brick.
You know a brick could keep a car from rolling
downhill or also a brick could become an obstacle.
Also some other things bricks could do I think
in your own group you form circles of ideas.
>>presenter: Yes.
Great.
So we have a question, yes.
>>female #1: Hi.
Can you hear me?
>>presenter: Yes.
Female #1: So you said before for that when
you all started you were kind of outside of
the establishment and that helped you be more
imaginative, more creative with your ideas
and I was wondering as you all got you know
more established and you got more clients
how did you bring that kind of discomfort
back in that sense of being outside of the
establishment back to your team?
>>Lester Wunderman: I didn't get it.
>>presenter: So, do you just want to repeat
it maybe a little louder?
female #1: So when you started you said that
being outside of the establishment kind of
gave you a sense of urgency to think imaginatively
and kind of come up with ideas that were outside
of what was currently being thought of.
How did you kind of recreate that urgency
and that sense of outside of the mainstream
when you started getting more clients and
kind of became part of the establishment?
>>Lester Wunderman: It becomes a tradition
in a company you know you can't let a company
grow stale and you try to if you're an executive
group and the company has a certain dynamic
you try to keep feeding it and encouraging
it.
And I think it's not just up to the people
who are creating the ideas it's up to those
who are responsible for them to encourage
everybody and the company not to make jobs
and “You’re a clerk and you’re a thinker
and you’re a…whatever” you know.
I think everybody, everybody-- I'm sure if
we took another half hour that and ask this
group to create some ideas on a subject you’d
get a hundred of them.
So if you don't ask for it you don't get it,
but if you don't encourage if you don't get
it.
You know that's the way it goes.
Good companies do that.
They become idea, idea companies.
>>presenter: Yes.
Yes.
>>presenter: Carley…
>>female#2: Mr. Wunderman, I'm curious to
know your opinions on political advertising
and how political advertising has evolved
from what you've seen throughout your career
and now today with so many different candidates
using digital to raise money and spread their
message and their brand.
>>Lester Wunderman: Well you know it's simply
a soapbox [laugh], an electronic soapbox.
I mean the tradition of a candidate standing
on a street corner and talking to his constituents
or other constituents goes back as long as
we know politics.
The fact that we have, uh, mass methods of
communication… they've taken that up and
I think it's a good idea.
I think we learn more about these candidates.
I remember the first one who did it was Franklin
Roosevelt who was President in my time—1932--and
he had his Fireside Chats and he had nothing
he had no political objective with his Fireside
Chats.
He just wanted people to feel that this was
a nation that acted together and could have
richer and better lives if they thought about
it in a certain way.
>>presenter: Great.
>>female#2: Thank you.
>>presenter: Thank you.
Any other questions from the audience?
Well Lester, on behalf of Google everyone
here thank you so much for taking the time
to spend with us.
This has been fantastic.
>>Lester Wunderman: Not at all.
[Applause]